[Music]
lynn is with us in minneapolis hi lynn
how are you
hi dave hi john thank you for taking my
call sure i am a huge huge fan thing and
i'm debt free thanks to you and your
program
i am 60 years old i make 55 000 a year
as an administrative assistant and yet i
still love paycheck to paycheck because
of my high rent but i love where i live
my my take home pay is 2600 a month and
my rent is 16.55
which is over half of my take-home pay
for a one-bedroom apartment
i've been looking at purchasing a condo
but the ones i like get outbidded and
the older condos which are more
affordable to buy um have a high like
seven hundred dollars in hoa fees and
i'm not comfortable with that high of a
key
so my question for you today is i really
like the convenience of renting
i'm wondering if it's in my best
interest to purchase something or if
it's okay to keep renting i i could find
a cheaper apartment that's not as nice
but it would be like two hundred dollars
less a month
okay
and i'm your your 2600 dollar number if
you make 50 000 is wrong
that's right yeah well 2600 is 30 000.
you don't have 20 thousand dollars in
taxes
you make 50 a year is that what your
salary is based on are you getting a
huge are you getting a huge refund or
are you counting stuff that's coming out
of your check other than taxes when
you're telling me what your take-home
pay is
oh i'm current like that's like what it
comes out from my benefits and my
retirement okay how much are you putting
in how much are you putting in
retirement
okay i do
i i do four percent which is required
for an eight percent match
and then i do another one percent on top
of that so that comes to
a year
okay your benefits expensive
are you getting up
you're getting a big tax refund every
year
i'm i'm not because i also get fossil
support and i have to pay taxes on that
okay
so i just i just keep i don't i just
keep out what i need for taxes and and i
got hit really big this year for some
reason yeah i'm still struggling with
how we go from a 50 000 income to a
thirty thousand dollar take-home pay
i'm trying to find where that money's
going okay and it didn't go to
retirement if they're like
my paychecks are like 13.84
and i get paid well maybe that's and i
do get paid 26 times a year
well that's a little bit better um
35 000 at this point but still there's
something there's still some money
i mean i'm not saying it's missing i
just don't know where you're what you're
doing with it exactly so okay the answer
to your question in overall without
trying to figure out what to do today
about it
is that if you're 60 for the next 30
years can you imagine what rents are
going to do
yeah that that scares me because they
they i had an increase one year of 150
dollars a month yeah and it's like it
that's the problem with being a renter
in perpetuation
is it's the largest portion of your
income goes to housing and you lose
control
of how much it increases
when you are at the mercy of the
landlord
and so you don't want to be a renter for
the next 30 years because that's gonna
you know it's gonna increase versus if
you bought that condo you know you've
locked in what it costs you not counting
the hoa fees but you've locked in your
cost per month for the next 30 years
and so i'm moving in some way towards
one of these condos in in some method
figuring out how i'm going to get there
and what have i got to do to cause that
to happen because that's a better
long-term
play for you
we also know that the folks that reach
you know reach a million dollar net
worth the vast majority of them well
over 80 percent of them
the primary source of their wealth is
two things they're retirement plans
and they're paid for house
and so you know if you end up with a 700
000 800 000 net worth
uh you know in in 10 or 15 years over
time here uh which you probably could do
a portion of that a third of that a
uh
half of that or whatever would be your
paid for condo that you got paid off in
the next 15 years so i want that
stability in your long term plan
that's why we don't want to be a renter
long term but it doesn't mean we're
stupid in the short term
and you go out there in the name of not
renting anymore or you go do something
foolish and buy something you can't
afford yeah
which is what a lot of young couples do
when they get married they have to rush
out and buy a house that they can't
afford or you're getting a bidding war
and suddenly you're yeah i don't think
she was very wise to walk away from
those bidding wars she said it went up
and i i tapped out that's right and
that's very very smart